oh
god michael what did you do i made the
trolley problem real so we could see how
the ethics would actually play out there
are five workers on this track and one
over there here are the lovers to switch
the tracks make a choice the thing is i
mean ethically speaking no time to make
a decision oh it's tricky i mean on the
one hand if you ascribe to a purely
utilitarian wrongfu
okay
so
what did we learn
chidi
talk it out buddy
what are we thinking he thinks he just
killed a bunch of people with a trolley
it's just a simulation i would never
make you kill real people oh well that's
reassuring because some of the parts of
the fake people flew into my mouth
michael can we just go back to the
classroom we never left here i'll show
you
huh
look see buddy none of this was real
well they're fake people but their pain
is real does that make sense there have
to be stakes or it's just another
thought experiment this is awful you
specifically asked me if there's a way i
could connect with the material more
i'm trying you guys
i'm sorry
you're right i want to help you
understand this
thank you chidi
so let's try again
oh i i thought maybe we would have a
discussion no the whole point is to play
out the scenario in real time judy
what's your decision okay okay i can do
this i am choosing to switch tracks so
that way i only kill one person
oh forgot to tell you this is the
scenario where you actually know one of
the people it's your friend henry there
jd
how are you mate eric boo oh nice
trolley
i can't cheating my boots are stuck in
the trash
anyway
oh my god
again just the simulation and almost
impossibly life-like simulation
oh
i can't do it come on dude
it's dangerous is what it is
vicki could find out and then the you
know the the plan the whole plan
it's bad for the plan janet that that's
the reason i don't understand given the
situation it's far safer to initiate the
self-destruct
okay look see here here's the reason see
i promised the four humans that we would
escape to the good place once and for
all and without you
we stand zero chance of ever making it
there the new janet will be able to help
you with that well i agree but it's not
only that though see it's also because
of um
well what if
vicky found out you already asked me
that
why are you making such a big deal about
turning me into a marble forever because
of reasons there are reasons they exist
and i just don't want to explain them
right now what are the reasons
they're reasons janet okay but what are
they the reason is friends
[Music]
you're my friend janet that's why i
can't kill you
we have been through so much together i
mean yeah sure for you you know each
time i rebooted you you you met me all
over again but for me our
our relationship has become
important
you're my oldest my truest
my most loyal friend
i can't just get rid of you and
replace you with some other janet i
don't even know
holy mother forking shirt
balls what
wow
okay
okay
yo mikey sean
come on out
is everything okay
right is rain mikey my boy so
chidi and i are gonna go to the bad
place what trust me i've got this
that's our decision let's hit it well
what about real life no it's me and
chidi call the train
point of order i don't accept this offer
the real mistakes were jason and ellen
you said any two of us it's me and chidi
let's do it to it
michael i just found an obscure
precedent in the rules that might just
save everyone fuzz off bamba john don't
need it
uh okay
ready when you are boss
eleanor what's going on
it took me a while to figure it out
but just now as we were all fighting and
yelling at each other and each one of us
demanding we should go to the bad place
i thought to myself
man this is torture
and then it hit me they're never gonna
call a train to take us to the bad place
they can't
because we're already here
this is the bad place
[Music]
oh man
i can't believe you figured it out
oh
god
you ruined everything you know that
you will never be at peace until you get
the one thing you truly want
[Music]
i'm
i'm gonna be a real boy pinocchio the
judge gave me the power to make you an
actual human
goodbye fire squid hello silver fox
oh eleanor
oh my goodness now you need to be sure
about this you're gonna live down there
for like
some amount of time you'll die really
die then you'll enter an afterlife test
be judged on what you did the whole deal
at least so we think
while you're down there this entire
system could be changed sean might
launch a coup someone could design a
whole new system you won't really know
what's going to happen to you
that's what makes it special
i won't exactly know what's going to
happen after i die
[Music]
nothing more human than that
besides texting people that you're five
minutes away when you haven't even left
the house
[Music]
thank you ellen
thank you
you're very welcome
hey mike where are you headed today
earth
actually oh
been a while
here's the return clicker no need
one-way trip
wow
okay
good luck
thank you
i have something for you
he's
real it's real he's a real frog yes it
sure is
thank you
you know what
i got the perfect name for him
mr jumpy legs oh
i thought you were gonna
never mind
hello mr jumpy legs
okay
so here's your driver's license and your
social security card
i set up a bank account for you there's
enough money in there so that you don't
starve but not so much that you become
an entitled jerk
thank you make a doctor's appointment as
soon as you get down there and no salty
food you have to keep your blood
pressure down you have blood now
i'll be fine
i'll be okay
i know i just worry
i'll see you again you know
i'll see you when i get back
okay
[Music]
if you rent a car don't pay for the
insurance it's a scam
okay
[Music]
man it's hot
but it's a it's a dry heat
[Music]
i can't believe they've managed to mix
one million flavors together and yet
somehow i can taste each individual one
it's remarkable i got no flavor
it's all i deserve really no look i i
appreciate you trying to cheer me up i
really do but you don't understand th
this was the very first neighborhood
that i got to design it was my chance to
prove myself and i've blown it you know
sometimes a floor can make something
even more beautiful like with cindy
crawford and how short she is oh tahani
if i made one tiny mistake in my design
if there's a single glitch in the system
if even one blade of grass is angled a a
fraction of a degree off
the whole neighborhood is
compromised
whose dog is that guys whose dog is that
whose dog is dad
see this is one of those glitches i was
talking about nice try puppy
that was a close one
teacup
have you seen my dog
[Music]
you